HE TURNED.
FLICKS THE FACE CROFT BACK TO
BROBERG AND NOW DEREK RYAN PUCKS
INTO THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
AND A FACE-OFF.
WANTED A SHOT R THE GLASS.cDAVIS
WIDE.
KNOWS HE HAS A LANE -- RIGHT
HERE.
SHORTHAND WIDE IS HOW HE PUTS I.
SAVE KOSKINEN.
REBOUND IN T T INTO THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
KANE IN THE HIGH SLOT.Y TO THE
NOW IT'S McDAVID IN FRONT.
YAMAMOTO TUCKS IT HOME!
WASHINGTON CAPITALS. AND DRIVEST
THROUGH FROM A SHARP LEDDY.
A SHOOT REDIRECT.
A LITTLE BIT OF A CHINTZY CALL
ON A LITTLE BIT OF THE SLASH
YOU TURN THE PUCK OVER. ON SIDE.
A SHOT SMOTHERED.
JUOLEVI.
BUT HE STAYS WITH IT.
EVANDER
SHOT, SCORE!
LUCAS RAYMOND! FORECHECK.
AND THISFOEGELE REDIRECT IT HOM?
DRAISAITL NET EMPTY.
HERE.
NICE CLOSE BY NURSE TO GET THE
PUCK TO McDAVID, AND HE MAKES
THE PLAY.
HE FINDS THE OPEN M